hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a South Korean fantasy
romance show called Alchemy of souls
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the show opens up on the streets where
an elderly woman stops by some roadside
Baggers she later brings them to her
house lets them have some quality meals
and leaves right then a devilish looking
man with blue skin color appears and
tries to attack the Beggars he is about
to kill them but luckily a Demon Slayer
Jang Kang arrives there and throws it
away Jang then uses Supreme water
control powers and confines the Devil
Within it impaling it badly it turns out
the creature is actually the son of the
same elderly woman she begs Jang to
bring him back to normalcy as he was the
one who mis-executed the Forbidden
soul-shifting technique on her son and
made him go wild but to her dismay Jang
refuses to do it and mentions that it is
useless as her son has already gone too
far ultimately Jank throws the creature
into the ocean which upon losing its
energy transforms into a rock I can
already tell this Show's gonna slap in
the following scene an ailing Emperor
discovers these failed all shifting
experiments by Jang and invites him to
the Palace however instead of punishing
him the emperor requests Jiang to
exchange Souls with him for a few days
so that he can conceive an heir to the
throne I'm going to need to borrow that
dick at first the Demon Slayer refuses
claiming it is dangerous but when the
stubborn Emperor insists he gives in
soon Jang Begins the Forbidden procedure
and successfully exchanges Souls with
the emperor however as soon as it is
done the emperor rushes to meet Zhang's
wife dohua he immediately begins making
love with her and the poor woman happily
complies unaware that it is not her
husband dark the scene then fast
forwards by 20 years where we are
introduced to naksu a skilled assassin
who has been killing Mages she fights
with Park Jin the leader of the park
Family one of the top four families in
the city of daiho naksu manages to
defeat a large number of soldiers alone
but she is ultimately overpowered by
Park Jin who injures her with his sword
left with no options she flees the
Battlefield and quickly transforms her
soul into a different body soon Park Jin
also arrives and when he finds out that
naksu has interchanged bodies he is
livid nonetheless he takes her body and
her sword hoping she will return for
them elsewhere noxy was possessed the
body of a girl named moodyak it turns
out she is a blind girl who is about to
be sold to a brothel however after the
switch noxu has retained some of her
qualities because of which she is able
to see clearly later when she is brought
to the brothel a senior female
approaches her and makes her aware of
the four seasons of daiho it turns out
that a group of four talented and
appealing offspring of the four
prestigious families the park Family the
co family the Jinn family and the Jang
family represent four different seasons
in daiho after hearing this naxu
remembers that these are the very
descendants of the people who had killed
her parents when she was a child a
murder that she witnessed later naxi
tries to flee the brothel and on the way
she stumbles upon one of the princes of
the place Jang despite being the son of
Jang Kang he is alluded to be The
Offspring of his mother's extramarital
relationship when Natsu attempts to Rob
him of his money janguke convinces her
into stealing his Jade plaque instead
and allows her to flee as she runs away
jangyuk seems impressed by her moves and
guesses her to be the real naksu
elsewhere the group for which Knox who
previously worked as an assassin wants
to remove all of her traces so that no
one can ever relate them with naksu in
the following scene Natsu visits the
market to sell the plaque that she got
from janguke right then she notices of
the co family and remembers that he is
the one to whom she gifted her bird
whistle during their young age at the
buyer's shop suddenly a few guards from
the Jang family arrive and capture her
afterward Knox who is brought back to
Zhang Yuk's place where he reveals that
he has purchased her from the brothel he
now intends to use her as his personal
maid having no other options left naksu
agrees to follow jangook's orders later
she discovers that jang-uk has a plaque
that she can use to enter songram a
secret place where Mages and Royals
train magical spells and improve their
skills naksu is well aware that she
needs to gain back her powers before
entering the place yet she makes the
decision to enter song room discreetly
hoping that her sword will help her
regain some of her powers later at night
after Jang ook falls asleep Natsu steals
his plaque and runs to songram soon
Zhang UK also opens his eyes and it
appears as if he was well aware of
what's Happening meanwhile knocks you
enter song room to get her sword back
but finds the place being attacked by a
group of Shadow assassins they light a
fire in the training center and attack
the guards naxu watches from afar as the
Four Season soldiers Stave off the
Assassins which appear to have been sent
by a guy in a black cloak who worked as
naxu's Superior while the two groups are
fighting naxu runs towards youngjin gak
a training center where Mages and people
of songram are trained here she gets to
know that the Assassins have been sent
by her Superior career to get hold of
these items meanwhile after realizing
that the fire in the training center is
simply a diversion Park Jin the leader
of songrem rushes to jianjin gak however
to his shock noxy's body and sword have
already been stolen by the shadow
attackers he then urges everyone to look
for the Invaders and capture them before
they manage to flee while looking around
coyul spots naksu and begins chasing
after her he is about to catch up to her
when suddenly Jang ook steps in to save
her day he pulls her to a safer place
and under the Moonlight observes a
distinctive pattern in noxy's eyes
looking at her Jang ook mentions that
she is supposed to be the master he is
looking for here the scene flashes to
the past and it is revealed that Jang
ook is the one whom dohua had given
birth to right before she died sadly
Jang hang refused to accept him as his
son and also blocked his gate of energy
hindering him from using any super
powers back to the present Zhang UK
reveals to naksu that he knows about her
true identity in exchange for protecting
her he begs her to serve as his master
right then Co you will notice his naksu
and tries to attack her with his sword
but janguke again manages to save her
seeing him CIO gets surprised and
apologizes for his sudden attack soon
Park dangoo a descendant of the park
family also joins them while janguke and
sioyul are talking about past incidents
sometime later jangook introduces
moodyak AKA Natsu as his personal maid
and CEO you will apologizes for chasing
her earlier Park dangoo also Praises her
for making an effort to protect her
master they then informed the duo about
naksu's missing body elsewhere Park Jin
learns that a spy is hiding in songram
and orders his men to identify him or
her afterward in the secret chamber
where her original body was capped naksu
janguke suyul and park dangu gather and
start to discuss to knox's annoyance
jangyuk keeps insulting her real self
making her frustrated and even more
determined to eliminate him soon after
the two are left alone jangyuk coerces
her to reveal her true identity and she
admits that she is naksu in turn she
asks him about his motivation for
assisting her jangyuk says that he wants
her to serve as his master surprisingly
naksu declines his offer compelling
jang-uk to use a hidden device to
confine themselves inside yonjingak he
then warns naksu that if she kills him
soldiers of songrim will find her when
they open the chamber but if she accepts
his offer to be his master he can
protect her from getting killed later
after describing how weak she has become
due to the soul shifting Natsu informs
jangyuk that she needs to find her sword
to regain her powers she also mentions
that she will need her sword to open his
energy gate which was closed years ago
hearing this jangyuk asserts that they
can't attempt to open the locks until
the closing mechanism ends this
infuriates naksu and she tries to strike
zanyuk but in the process she
unknowingly steps on a floor switch
causing the floor to collapse later the
2 managed to escape the secret room only
to be taken to the training center where
Park Jin has requested everyone to
gather they also meet park dangu there
who tells them that Park Jin has
assembled them there to look for naksu's
men who are believed to be responsible
for the attack according to park gen
there is a soul-shifting traitor among
them who will be exposed with the aid of
the Jinn family's ghost as soon as he
says so a princess from the Gin family
arrives with a strange vessel and
unleashes the sorcery detecting ghost
named sasali guingu it slowly flies out
from the antique pottery and starts to
look around taking on the shape of an
animal just as jangook and Natsu
anticipate an attack from it guigu leaps
upon another Soul shifter behind them
the latter tries to escape but SEO
you'll easily finishes him off with a
single strike meanwhile Knox who've used
this as a chance to escape but when
guigu returns to his psalter she is
caught by jang-uk after directing her to
flee janguke himself dashes back to the
training facility and smashes the
Priceless Pottery eliminating guigu and
therefore rescuing naksu however because
of this park Jin and the family
reprimand him Jang Hook is then given
the punishment to stay outside for the
night during this time naksu visits the
brothel and purchases some explosives
from the owner in exchange she trades
Jang ook's song Rim Spirit plaque that
she had been carrying around the scene
then switches to the men's meeting site
in donju where the leader pledges to
transform everyone who brought naxu's
body to them into Soul shifters but as
soon as the leader leaves the room his
men kill everyone who helped in bringing
noxu there the leader is revealed to be
a powerful Chief named jinmu following
the massacre everyone in the area starts
believing that jinmu is the one who
brought naksu and her men's bodies back
to the Palace at the palace for his
Brave act the emperor tries to appoint
jinmu as the guanju the leader of the
soldiers but the song remembers oppose
it they believe that since Jang Kang is
still the Guangzhou the decision is
baseless the Emperor then Alters the
prize for jinmu and fulfills his request
to publicly burn noxus corpse while
retaining her sword at chion buguan a
place which is used to keep valuable
items of royal families safely later
when Jang ook gets to know about this he
goes to meet jinmu to get naksu's sword
at first the latter refuses to comply
but when jangyuk mentions that he is the
son of the current guanju jinmu quietly
hands the sword over meanwhile Natsu
makes her way to the place where her
real body is being set on fire this
devastates naksu but when janguke
approaches her with her sword she cheers
up a bit the two then move to a
different location where noksu tries to
unsheath her sword but fails seeing this
janguke be rates her saying that she is
not qualified enough to be his master
disappointed that she has become a total
failure naxu leaves to commit the
unthinkable later she goes to the edge
of like uh young chandai ho and
remembers jinmu calling it the cemetery
of Soul shifters naksu then dives into
the water her and as soon as she reaches
the depths she feels energized this time
she successfully takes her sword out of
its sheath soon after Jang ook also
arrives there and is surprised to see
naxu by the lake with her blade
unsheathed he rushes to check up on her
but naksu abruptly passes out in
sejuquan the official infirmary of the
Royals Into the Mages noxu awakens and
tries to draw her sword but fails she
then learns from janguke that it was the
lake which allowed her to draw the sword
there is a magical strength inside the
waters which cannot be found anywhere
else hearing this Natsu realizes that
she requires a powerful person to drive
the energy out of her so she devises a
new strategy at night while the two are
conversing Jang ook drinks a cup of
herbal tea as soon as he does so naxu
reveals that she is actually poisoned
the drink and the only way to bring him
out of the poisons effect is by opening
the gate of energy right then Park Jin
and his senior arrive at the scene and
seeing Zhang UK in pain they rush to
help naxu tells them about the poison
and the fact that Jiang yuk has only six
hours left until his heart stops she
also reveals that the only way to rescue
him is by opening his gate of energy
sounds like a euphemism what are you
playing at however Park Jin is only
interested in knowing the name of the
poison she fed to his friend when she
remains silent he takes naksu away and
punishes her brutally but despite this
she remains tight-lipped leaving them
with no option but to open his gate of
energy sometime later hyoyam the senior
of the Jang family approaches Jang ook
and unlocks his gate of energy to save
him the procedure works and he slowly
regains Consciousness surprisingly when
he learns that noxu is being kept
hostage for poisoning him he rushes to
save her he quickly unties the ropes
from noxus hands and legs and they both
finally address each other as master and
pupil poison me again mommy the scene
then flashes back to the past when Park
Jin questions Jang Kang regarding his
son's origins in the rationale behind
shutting down his energy Gates Jan Kang
responds by saying he is doing so to
safeguard the child from being
ill-treated and to free him from extra
pressure back to the present Zhang UK
brings naksu back to the shelter and
when he sees Park Jin he starts
apologizing he lies that he poisoned
himself and begs for his approval to
take Knox due to sejuquan to have her
wounds treated as expected Park Jin gets
enraged but CEO Yule and park dangoo
calm him down and somehow convince him
to let the duo receive treatment after
this as Jang ook is trying to assist
noxy to her feet he notices a blue Mark
developing in her eyes fearing that she
will be exposed he quickly covers her
eyes after a while with the help of SEO
Yule and park dangoo they leave for seju
Quan afterward we see master hyoyam and
park Jin debating the earlier incident
how yam admits that in order to speed up
zhanguk's recovery he gave him his own
energy which is worth 10 years this
surprises Park Jin and he requests yoyam
to take back his energy as soon as
possible however the master refuses on
the other hand and given that noxy's
behavior has been anything but typical
we can see that CEO Yule is starting to
have doubts about her the scene then
shifts to Jang ook and naksu who are
currently at sejuquan and talking about
the previous incidents afterward zhanguk
states that no one has ever jeopardized
her life for him or understood his need
as she did and now as both of them are
alive he promises to accept her as his
master Zhang UK then prepares to bow
down to his new master but naksu
interrupts him and puts forward some
conditions no one should find out about
their Master pupil relationship and that
they need to depart once their
objectives are achieved naksu will
promptly leave after she transforms into
her original form since he won't have
any incentive to protect her later jinmu
admits to killing the physical form of
noxu's soul-containing body but when he
asks his subordinate about the blue mark
on her body the latter lies that it was
already on the corpse at the time of the
examination jinmu then deduces that
naksu must have used all her energy
because of which she was unable to fight
back he recalls the past when Jang Kang
had his soul switched into the emperor's
body it is then revealed that this
incident is what inspired him to learn
about Soul shifting from Jang Kang next
noxy starts her teachings with janguke
and tells him about the three
requirements for being the finest Mage
in all the land during their classes she
quickly learns that he has no background
in martial arts making it even more
difficult for her to train him in the
following scene as naxi was cleaning
outside sejuquan she and master hyoyam
get into a minor argument however he
tells her not to be offended as his
wrath is only directed at jang-uk
hiyoyam also tells her that he genuinely
loves Jungkook and has invested his
energies to help him recover faster when
the latter also confirms this naksu
becomes excited she now intends to steal
this energy for him but in order to do
so she needs hyoyam's breathing
technique as xyo Yul is a member of
hyoyam's family and is probably using a
similar breathing pattern Natsu pursues
him to learn the technique see you will
then becomes intrigued and gets closer
to her but as he is about to explain his
breathing pattern Jang ook arrives there
and ruins the whole setup he then
reveals to naksu that he has already
managed to acquire the breathing skill
from hyoyam and is currently practicing
it later a new character the Crown
Prince of daiho go wan is introduced he
is revealed to be jinmu's student and
the latter informs him that Zhang UK has
taken naksu's sword despite the fact
that the emperor gave it to him hearing
this Gohan gets angry at shinmu and
criticizes him go on with your bad self
later Park Jin calls jangyuk up to the
main hall and announces his expulsion
from the song Ram group making everyone
surprised when zhangyuk doesn't return
the spirit plaque he is subsequently
given a superior a severe punishment of
100 floggings after this jangu and naksu
can be seen leaving songram carrying
their personal belongings in a flashback
Park Jin's motivation was made clear
when Jang hang revealed to him the Jang
is actually the late Emperor's Offspring
now the only way to protect him from
being the new emperor is by never
allowing him to enter his Gates the
episode ends with Jang Kang stating the
jangyuk can survive if he quietly lives
as his son but if he doesn't death is
imminent subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching